[تصفيق]
يريد الديموقراطيون المتطرفون تحويل
أمريكا إلى كوبا شيوعية أو فنزويلا الاشتراكية
، وأنت تتذكر يوم 6 كانون الثاني (يناير) الغوغاء الغاضبون
الذين اقتحموا مبنى الكابيتول الأمريكي ، هاجموا
سلطات إنفاذ القانون لتعقب المسؤولين المنتخبين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
[  موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى
] والآن من أجل جعل بلدنا
ناجحًا وآمنًا ومجدًا ،
ربما يتعين علي فعل ذلك مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شكرًا لك
أننا نعلم في عظامنا أن
ديمقراطيتنا في خطر ونحن  اعلم أن هذه هي
لحظتك للدفاع عنها والحفاظ على الحماية
واختيارها في العام الذي سنستعيد فيه
المنزل الذي
سنستعيد فيه مجلس الشيوخ
وسنستعيد أمريكا وفي عام 2024 الأهم أننا
سوف يستعيدون أعمالنا الرائعة
مرتين
[تصفيق]